this video is brought to you by
expressvpn learn more at
expressvpn.comwisecrack
[Music]
if you've spent a handful of hours on
cable television internet comment
threads a bookstore or even a local town
hall
you might have noticed a pattern
wherever you go whatever you watch
whatever you read adolf hitler is
everywhere you can tune into hunting
hitler hitler's secret tunnels or
hunting nazi treasure on history
or flip over to the smithsonian channel
for secrets of the third reich or
treblinka hitler's killing machine
if you're still not satisfied there's
nazi megastructures or hitler's last
stand on national geographic
and let's not forget netflix where you
can watch hitler's circle of evil the
dark charisma of adolf hitler
hitler a career hitler of the andes nazi
concentration camps hitler's olympics
hitler's steel beast
the last nazis and auschwitz the nazis
and the final solution
secret hitler which i hear is a great
game raised almost 1.5
million dollars on kickstarter and who
can deny the pure joy of the countless
downfall memes
today we're going to talk about what i
would like to call the hitler industrial
complex
this is not some shadowy conspiracy but
the very observable fact that hitler's
image has made millions
if not billions of dollars for authors
television executives
and filmmakers vice even called hitler
the biggest pop star of them all
as a result hitler has become more than
just a villain of history that we
eagerly consume
his image or rather the hatred of that
image has become
a guiding force in culture and politics
and as always i'm here to ask
why how and is this a good thing welcome
to this wisecrack edition on the hitler
industrial complex
and spoilers ahead for world war ii i
guess
so first things first has hitler after
the end of world war ii
always dominated culture like he does
today how did he become
a modern pop star during world war ii in
conjunction with the office of war
information
hollywood made scores of patriotic
pro-war movies and radio programs to
help the war effort at the same time a
score of pro-war comics were released
these were either some combination of
personal conviction to drum up support
for the war
collaborations with the us government or
simply cashing in on anti-german fervor
so we get captain america superman and
batman all
fighting hitler at various points even
if only on the covers
after the war the media churned out a
few hitler-related films and television
shows but the real floodgates of hitler
content opened in the 1980s
a quick stroll through wikipedia's list
of holocaust films supports this
in the 60s there was one american
holocaust documentary
in the 70s again only one in the 80s
there were 13 and by the 90s that number
jumped to
30. and today well we can see a similar
trend in narrative films professor
miriam gebauer attributes some of this
shift to the effects of 1960s
counterculture
which stressed openness over silence on
television historian ian kershaw locates
1979's docudrama entitled simply
holocaust as the moment that signaled a
flood of holocaust content
often these films served a dual role on
the one hand they brought awareness to
the public about historical tragedies
on the other you know money plenty of
networks and individuals contributed to
the commercialization of hitler and
holocaust media
but all of these contributions pale in
comparison to that of a
e as mark shown wrote in salon in 1997
ever since d-day nazis have been a
shortcut to box office
and now cable tv's success years ago the
discovery channel and a
e discovered they could juice up their
ratings with heavy doses of hitler
so much so that tv guide in 1992 derided
the cable twins as collectively forming
the hitler channel but sensing their
audience had fewer fatigue
the network retired him a e however
didn't give up
and spun off the history channel in
1995.
in 1997 shown notes the young network
aired as many as
40 hours of world war ii programming
weekly and sometimes as many as 12
hours in a single day the decision was
largely cynical
more content attracted a good
demographic for advertisers
affluent white males from ages 24 to 54.
this strategy eventually ran its course
as hitler content was pushed to the
periphery of history's schedule as the
network found success in other shows
and today while one can still find a
good deal of hitler content on history
you're much more likely to find swamp
people pawn stars or ancient aliens
but even if in general film or
television related to hitler
the holocaust or world war ii has waned
they still
constitute a major cultural pillar for
americans
so much so that the hitler industrial
complex has become its own
self-sustaining feedback loop as kershaw
writes and because there is such
widespread and apparently
ceaseless interest in hitler nazism and
the holocaust
publishers are keen to bring out books
on these topics since they know
they will sell journalists are keen to
write articles since they know
magazines will want to publish them and
television producers are keen to make
documentaries in feature films since
they know there's an audience for them
all this means that the third reich is
kept in the public eye
so the spiral continues the mass media
exploit the often lurid interest they
have helped to create
in the first place there's much more to
this feedback loop than just
too much content on what kind of drugs
hitler took he has become the de facto
symbol of evil and political wrongness
as godwin's law states as every internet
conversation goes on in duration
the chances of something or someone
getting compared to hitler
approaches a hundred percent no modern
politician has escaped the comparison to
the fuhrer
hillary clinton george w bush barack
obama and donald trump to name a few
recently when new york began mandating
vaccinations anti-vaxxer parents put on
gold stars to compare their treatment to
that of jews during the third reich
why is hitler a focal point of american
politics of all political persuasions
why has his memory commanded so much
attention now the easy answer would be
because he killed a bunch of people
stupid
but in a world where anyone can
weaponize hitler's image for any reason
or purpose
fairly or not it's worth asking does
political discourse
benefit from a symbolic and historical
representation of evil
to answer that question we should first
ask who was hitler before hitler
if when things get real dark the fuhrer
is our go-to reference
what did people do before the rise of
nazism
unlike today where hitler is your
one-stop shop for all malfeasance
back then if you wanted an analogy for
the villains ruining everything
you had to shop around and consider all
of history's tyrants and criminals
this is according to historian gavriel d
rosenfeld who asks this very question in
a 2018 paper
rosenfeld methodically details a litany
of ways that hitler was compared to
previous figures
as hitler rose to power different
analogies were drawn with different
historical figures
so before he controlled germany many
journalists compared the not yet fuhrer
to
georges bolange he was a general during
the french revolution who flirted with
seizing power and gained political
support by stoking anti-german sentiment
after the french defeat in the
franco-prussian war compare this to
hitler who stoked anti-french sentiments
after their defeat in world war 1
and the analogy seems apt when the
reichstag was set on fire the new york
times compared hitler to nero
whereas hitler blamed the fire on
bolsheviks in order to suspend civil
liberties
nero as tacitus claimed set fire to rome
and blamed it on the christians in order
to clear new land for construction
after hitler seized power people began
comparing him to political figures like
napoleon
sometimes favorably after the night of
the long knives one paper declared that
germany had reverted back to the times
of richard iii
while another compared it to the saint
bartholomew's day massacre of 1572
when thousands of french huguenots were
killed by catholic mobs
for rosenfeld the most common analogy
was the french revolution and robus
pierre with the political purging and
all
when hitler tried to assert control over
germany's catholic and protestant
churches he was compared to henry viii
who made the church of england withdraw
from papal control so he could get a
divorce
when it came to anti-semitism hitler was
often compared to historical leaders who
did the jews dirty
the egyptian pharaoh of exodus haman or
antiochus iv
similarly some christians compared the
persecution of jews with figures who
long ago persecuted christians
again nero and herod the first after the
war broke out analogies shifted to
historical conquerors
philip of macedon attila the hun genghis
khan and
more of napoleon these analogies are
diverse and draw from
many different historical contexts
analogies like these helped people make
sense of the world
and how to react to it before his rise
to power was he a clown to dismiss
or a serious threat to the world as
rosenfeld notes
the analogy served the dual goals of
description and prescription
by attempting to render hitler
intelligible they sought to determine
how he should be confronted but the
usefulness of political analogies is
up for debate depending on who you ask
comparing someone to julius caesar or
adolf hitler is either a necessary way
for humans to parse complicated
information
and make sense of the world or a useless
exercise in drawing cherry-pick
similarities to spin a compelling
narrative
there's even historical evidence that
poorly thought out political analogies
helped contribute to the rise of a
totalitarian leader
joseph stalin rosenfeld citing e.h carr
notes that many bolshevik leaders
rejected trotsky as lenin's successor
because he looked more like napoleon
than stalin did
and if he looks like napoleon then i
guess he must act like him too
but nothing made the problem of
analogies more apparent than when the
true
depth of nazi crimes made their way into
public awareness
as hana arendt wrote 20th century
totalitarianism
stands apart from the horrific crimes of
the past by their sheer
novelty the complete liquidation of the
modern state and freedom in favor of
unflinching loyalty to the party married
with a penchant for mass murder and
imperialism say what you will of robus
pierre or philip of macedon they were no
adolf hitlers they had no death camps
nor panzers nor radio or film when the
full extent of nazi misdeeds was known
an apt analogy became impossible because
these analogies seemed like a poor fit
for the specifics of the third reich
writers fled to the realm of theology to
the devil himself
in the process rosenfeld writes hitler
was transformed into western
civilization's new archetype of evil
whereas pre-world war ii writers drew
from a diverse range of religious and
political figures to define
evil post-world war ii the failure of
these figures to describe
20th century totalitarianism birthed a
monopoly on the matter
hitler became for political evil what
amazon became for books
every other figure had to close up shop
as a result
in modern day politics we have nowhere
else to turn
consider the representations of evil in
modern cinema and literature
voldemort and his death eaters with
their calls for wizard purity
are a clear stand-in for the third reich
george lucas went right ahead and called
his bad guys stormtroopers
after the nazi paramilitary soldiers and
even the lion king can't resist
comparing scar to hitler with specific
shots lifted from triumph of the will
and this has had some questionable
results in modern history
a favorite political analogy of world
leaders is the munich agreement
a concession of france and england to
let hitler annex part of czechoslovakia
in order to maintain
peace it has since become shorthand for
appeasing dictators
as tom shockman writes in foreign policy
the analogy has been used by john f
kennedy during the cuban missile crisis
john kerry to argue for strikes against
syrian president bashar al-assad
and by both bush presidents in regard to
war with saddam hussein
of his decision to pour troops into
vietnam lyndon johnson later wrote
everything i knew about history told me
that if i got out of vietnam and let ho
chi minh run through the streets of
saigon
then i'd be doing exactly what
chamberlain did in world war ii
i'd be giving a big fat reward to
aggression
of course you could be for or against
any of these decisions but that's not
the point
it doesn't take a whole lot of critical
thinking to realize that germany
that could have plausibly conquered all
of europe and defeated america in an
all-out war
is not the same as any of these examples
the problem with the hitler analogy is
that it doesn't afford
any nuance hitler as a symbol of evil
offers no shades of gray
and may lead to an oversimplified
political calculus but it's not just
that hitler is our one-stop shop for
reacting to the current world
he even once dictated the terms which we
can describe history
as rosenfeld notes hitler's crimes were
projected
into the past hannibal the carthaginian
general was called an ancient hitler
as well as pharaoh thutmosa iii virginia
governor william berkeley was called a
17th century hitler
whose cruelty had brought on bacon's
rebellion hitler once called the
napoleon of his day
now got the upper hand as napoleon was
now just the hitler of the 18th century
there was even a book called hitler
through the ages which claimed that
every historical age had its own hitler
and hitlerize became a verb in the
united states
lobbied by people on the left and right
to describe the prescription
that one was taking over democratic
institutions
today invoking hitler or the third reich
is a regular rhetorical tool
used by political candidates and
congress people alike let me just
clarify
are you saying that america is like nazi
germany
analogies like these even the hitler
sort can be
helpful as rosenfeld writes because
analogies help
render complex subjects intelligible
through simplification
they have been praised as vital
analytical tools that help people make
sense of the world but there's also a
trap with analogies
rosenfeld argues that they are
essentially cognitive shortcuts
they're substitutes for rather than
expressions of detailed analysis
their simplicity however makes them
tempting for both producers and
consumers
academic theorists often identify the
repetition of historical events in order
to create
elegant laws and generalizations the
general public meanwhile prefers
brief uncomplicated and racy
formulations to those that are more
complicated
as a result analogies can short-circuit
critical reflection
and lead to superficial thinking while
these simplifications are all over
political discourse it doesn't take much
to draw a line to social media
where similar analogies run rampant
through memes tweets
etc and in a world where adolf hitler is
the de facto genocidal maniac of all
genocidal maniacs
other lessons from history seem to be
easily passed over
and just to be clear he is just as bad
as all the rhetoric suggests
but that's not the point the point is
hitler having monopolized our discourse
on evil
isn't productive for a world that
requires complex thought
to tackle complex issues rosenfeld notes
part of the reason hitler is the
hegemonic figure of evilness is because
the world in the aftermath of world war
ii
wanted to make sure nothing similar
would ever happen again
and while like all good historical
analysis that is important
the centrality of hitler in the
conversation goes above and beyond
often obscuring other things we would
also like to never happen again
while some of these numbers are hard to
calculate and some are harder to
calculate than others
some argue that 17 million people died
from nazi persecution
by contrast under stalin's dictatorship
numbers range anywhere from 3 to 9
million
the transport of slaves across the
atlantic is somewhere around 2 million
somewhere between 1.6 and 1.9 million
people died in the cambodian genocide
and in the belgian congo
king leopold ii killed an estimated 10
million people
this number is probably hardest of all
to calculate but the amount of
indigenous people who died after
colonists
arrived into the new world ranges widely
some sources say 20 million while a
recent data-driven estimate puts the
number
at 56 million and then there's rwanda
indonesia and unfortunately a ton of
other world tragedies
but the interest in adolf hitler far
exceeds the interest in these other
historical crimes
google trends shows that online interest
in hitler dwarfs
every aforementioned tragedy and it
doesn't even seem to be because of scale
or recency
it out competes pol pot who instigated
the cambodian genocide by over
40 to one and yes hitler killed more
people than pol pot but not 40 times as
many
we can also look at google engrams which
tracks word and phrase usage in google
books massive corpus
and find that the phrase adolf hitler is
used nearly four times as much as joseph
stalin or leopold ii
as historian ian kershaw notes this has
happened with no other 20th century
dictator
not with mussolini franco mao pol pot
even stalin
however nasty their regimes however
vicious their repression however
horrific their inhumanity
they leave little mark on our
present-day consciousness
as a result the hitler industrial
complex seems to have obscured many
other historical tragedies when it comes
to thinking about
and analyzing the world if analogies are
useful at all
there's certainly not a
one-size-fits-all method we have to ask
if we're forgetting the other lessons
history has to offer
that's not to say hitler as an analogy
doesn't have its uses
as neo-fascist groups gain prominence
around the globe like greece's golden
dawn
comparisons to the anti-democratic and
xenophobic populism of hitler
may be appropriate but it's equally
important to see how these groups
diverge historically
how these modern movements have
developed and evolved and what other
historical connections they draw from
when is a comparison to hitler or the
nazis productive
if a group or leader has expansionists
nationalistic anti-democratic
and xenophobic tendencies well what if
they're nationalistic
anti-democratic and xenophobic but not
expansionist
is that enough do they have to wear
swastikas on their arms
we might also ask if exploring where the
analogy fails can give us better insight
into the world
it's a complicated issue and there's no
easy answer
so what do you think are political
analogies a necessary evil in
understanding the world
or should we avoid them at all costs is
the hitler industrial complex making
sure history never repeats itself by
producing documentaries like
secrets of the nazi occult why hitler's
amphetamine-fueled vegetarianism was
influenced by ancient aliens
let us know what you think in the
comments but before you go i want to
give a shout out to this week's sponsor
expressvpn by now most of you know a vpn
is a virtual private network
which encrypts all your online actions
and protects your information from
getting stolen
i'm always buying movie tickets on my
phone and hate losing connection when
i'm in the middle of picking my seat
so i'll log into one of those public
wi-fi hotspots but it can be pretty
risky
with a vpn i can be confident that
anytime i use my credit card my
information is protected
expressvpn has an app for every device
has the fastest service of any vpn
and is less than seven dollars a month
with a 30 day money back guarantee
so take back your internet privacy today
and find out how you can get three
months free
by clicking the link in the description
or by going to expressvpn.com
wisecrack thanks again to expressvpn and
as always
thank you all for watching peace
[Music]
you